this week has led many Americans to
consider issues of race with a fresh
urgency but coming to grips with our own
attitudes can be a challenge it's one
addressed in a groundbreaking book and
in the workshops it is now inspired
together
they've helped thousands of people look
deep into themselves as they look to
change the world around them across this
nation outrage wears many colors silence
equals white violence because white
people are the people oppressing black
people this show of recognition the
racism is real has taken on renewed life
in white people from protests in the
past the marches the Freedom Rides the
size and number of people of all races
on the street has grown an extension
from the unrest in the streets of
Ferguson Missouri in 2014 after Michael
Brown was gunned down by a white police
officer if these were white sons being
stopped like this that's when we first
discovered a small bimonthly support
group inside the st. Louis YWCA the
whole region has a race problem it was
called witnessing whiteness and in true
AAA fashion they acknowledge who they
are and who they seek to be I think by
having a group that's just white we can
ask that what people may consider the
dumb questions questions about bias
through history white privilege and
systemic racism and five years later
they're still at it
it has grown I think when you came to
see us we were on our first sort of
upward swing we caught up with them to
get their thoughts on what they've
learned and reaction to what's happening
now
Mary Ferguson was a group facilitator in
2014 you don't have to know exactly the
right thing to do we just have to resist
what are some
the things that we know are wrong to do
we have to change our mindsets and our
behavior bill Gilbert has been
witnessing whiteness since 2011 you look
at from Michael Brown to george floyd
what lens are you seeing this through
having done this work that's a that's a
good question not a whole lot has
changed actually I've been through many
classes many programs and I learned
something every time I'm pretty smart
but I just can't I can't be in a black
person's shoes and I just have to in
order to understand better what's going
on I need to hear more and talk more and
listen a lot more in 2008 dr. Shelly Tek
look understood that need and penned
witnessing whiteness her how-to guide on
anti racism this was one out of this
idea of wanting to help myself and then
therefore help other people to know all
those nooks and crannies of how racist
conditioning has gotten into us so that
we can actually recognize it stop it
name it when it's happening in front of
us and do something to move us toward
justice sounds like this is a form of
lifelong therapy it is this is
absolutely a healing journey undoing the
400 year momentum of systemic racism
won't be easy but these Americans
including married ins Moore are
committed you're doing like the internal
work of white anti-racism work is
something that I'm just gonna need to be
doing my whole life and hopefully if
enough of us you know do it it can it
can make a bigger change so we can make
bigger systemic change like what we
really need
Mary Ferguson said the group pause
sessions when the outbreak started but
this week they started those talks back
up again via zoom I asked dr. Shelley
how someone would begin such a hard
conversation with a loved one or a
friend she told me you start with an
invitation not finger pointing
Dayna Michelle I'm so glad I'm so glad
you revisited them we a couple weeks ago
this is I said to you I didn't have the
words I didn't even know how to ask the
questions and so to see some of this is
eye-opening for so many of us you know
we we have to be uncomfortable maybe to
figure some of this out yeah being
uncomfortable it's it's not easy but
it's well worth it